[Music]
January 1974 they just moved in two
months prior partner and I were first on
the scene he was feeling for a light and
something bumped him that's when we
found the little girl hanging from this
pike
I found someone to take over who'd be
very good for the BSU he wants to expand
the units and he intends to make our
approach practice
show me who someone you want more than
anything Manson I'll get you man sir
this is $100,000 and it's all yours
he'll help us identify the persons
behind the words of our children and
elect another time reported missing in
Atlanta sending you both mostly there
for the duration
so all these children won't kill I
believe that to be the case it's
statistically rare for serial killers to
cross racial lines
there's also statistically significant
that the Klan kills black people getting
on a barrel if he blows this gun will
rethink his investment in us can use the
theater department what it always say
that's so offended the city we need to
stay focused if you're distracting I
have some things to deal with it home
it's personal she had someone else's
underwear stuff down 10:30 do you know
where your children this is one predator
like if you're I'm not very self-serving
toward we can't have television
what evidence is there to suspect the
Klan son we've got 19 dead black
children you telling me that's a
coincidence one more thing man sent a
small like really small try not to stare
[Music]